we are brainwashed by a fake
spirituality there is
real spirituality within ourselves man
it is there and it's waiting only for
those earnest seekers
that really really strive towards it
but just like like like you can't come
into the kingdom of god unless you're
innocent like a child
you can't attend to this
pearl to this treasure you can dive in
deep
to actually get it if you're still there
right that's why you enquire you
disappear and that's when the pearl
shines right you know what why they say
the self or or god is is is self shining
it doesn't need something else to prove
that it is
it's it's quite different when we are
not there to search for it in objects it
reveals itself because we're not there
to obstruct our own view
right
theo welcome to the show
thanks for your invitation
i'm um
i'm glad to be here
we're happy to have you on
all hot and shirtless
you can use his nipples as a meditation
object if you'd like
no no no don't focus on objects that's
why you suffer don't use my nipples
use them just to move away from from
them that's all
yeah
that's good
so using your nipples as an entry point
what's uh
what are you hinting at right now moving
away from the objects towards what
where's the subject of course
i mean it's no problem everyone can
focus on objects as much as they want
but
they remain in the same uh in the same
subject object and the relationship and
it just uh
it just goes on further and further
instead of like cutting the knot and
like
yeah
right
and what do you mean by cutting the knot
um
well first of all let me just mention
this
something really beautiful
something very beautiful
and um
it might seem like a mystery this word
consciousness you know or
or awareness you know if we if we use
words and we don't know
uh
what they represent
it seems like it's a mystery but it's
not really a word that needs to be
represented it's just pretty much
uh remembering yourself let me put it
that way
so we can say consciousness or awareness
um um
it's not that we remember ourselves it's
just a way of putting it a very close a
very close way because it's still words
again
but a a very close way of or actually
coming closer to what we are it's not
that we come closer or further but
at one point
this is this is what i would say uh
you have to move from objects from
everything that comes and goes from
everything that passes
in this
open view let's call it uh
you gotta remain
let me stay like this just by yourself
because when the when the subject let's
call it the ego okay
uh which is the same consciousness but
somehow it has name and form because
it's still
uh it's still the same eye but having
name and form it simply survives by
clinging on to objects
so pretty much what's an object it can
be a thought it can be a feeling it can
be an emotion
it can be a physical object it can be
anything that pretty much
is outside of you what you call out of
it okay
so in the subject object relationship
where used to live all our lives okay
and pretty much when we cut this knot of
ego or or however you want to call it
we manage to remain as consciousness
itself without
any other object without looking at
objects without perceiving thoughts
without anything else we can remain as
we are basically the same
the same consciousness that
with with name and forms we call
ourselves whatever name and uh we
associate it with the body and we live
in the world
pretty much when it doesn't focus on
objects and it just focuses on itself
and it's not really consciousness that
does it consciousness simply is but it's
simply this this ego which can be
perceived if it doesn't stay in the
subject object relationship and just
pretty much focuses itself it just
disappears and what remains is
consciousness
just consciousness no objects no objects
whatsoever just consciousness
so i would say that's a way of putting
it a very simple way
the not being the ego which is not
really physical it's not
really
pure consciousness and somehow in
between
is this
is this suffer is this thing that that
makes you suffer by clinging on to
objects if it's not focused on objects
and it focuses on itself it just
it just vanishes
and then you of course you you you
you're able to remain just as you are
just just as you are of course until it
rises again
it clings to an object
you go back towards yourself again and
again and again and again until it's
impossible basically
to remain outside then you just you just
settle
as what you are
right
right so
for you you
your moment-to-moment experience is
no self
it's kind of no no no no no no no no
consciousness because if we say no self
people give the might get the wrong idea
like no self as in buddhism or
no no no it's our experience
to always be
the problem is that in wakefulness we're
more than what we are
that's why we suffer if we manage to
remain in wakefulness just as we are
basically exactly like in deep sleep you
can call it a week for deep sleep which
is somehow a contradiction but then we
don't speak about wakefulness or deep
sleep
okay you can just remain as
consciousness call it the self with
capital s or when i when i say no
self i pretty much mention like like no
person you know no ego no self no ego no
person but there's there's in everyone's
experience something that always remains
and it's no different than ourselves it
always abides as i
so just like you experience in deep
sleep
yourself you experience
yourself ungratefulness you experience
yourself in uh
in dreaming you always have the
experience basically of yourself it's
just that
when you dream or when you stay in
wakefulness identify with the body it
seems like you're something more than
what you are
that's the only problem it's not that
that
you you don't find yourself it's just
that you are more than
what you should be
right
right so for you doesn't even matter if
it's wake called wakefulness or capital
s self or no ego or no self it just
doesn't matter any of those descriptions
it's just a freaking word right it's
just that consciousness doesn't doesn't
matter just whatever
it abides always as i it's always abides
aside
it's not it's not the second person a
third person and even the ego itself
doesn't abide as the first person it
always abides as something else it
clings to objects which are seen
outside of ourselves so the ego itself
is the second you can see a second or a
third person because when it
when it inquires about itself it simply
vanishes there is no more ego and what
remains is just presence
right
right
nice
yeah so the moment that some sort of uh
some sort of like an external fixation
or grasping arises
um that that
sort of takes one away from what they
are and then it's just an untangling for
you
and how you share it it's an entangling
of that
phenomena to
what one always is before that
fixation or grasping or clinging
onto objects
yes pretty much whenever you fix objects
you have the experience of that object
but you lose the experience of yourself
whenever we attach to it it's like it's
like that when when what we think we
become
well of course if you think if you think
about your fears if you think about your
desires immediately you become that but
some would say no no no it's still me
yes yes it's still you but you have
something else
that that you gotta think of you know
and you
pretty much become your fear your desire
and it actually manifests emotionally
too when you are without your fears when
you are without your desires which are
pretty much just objects they appear
let's call it in this field of
consciousness just as objects before you
are pre-fine
without the fear you can stay like that
without fear even now so
but it can be anything it's physical
objects too that's why you can hear a
lot of sages saying that we shouldn't
focus on the world we shouldn't focus on
thoughts we shouldn't focus on anything
other than ourselves it's for this
simple reason
that whenever we we fix
something else
we pretty much just lose
our real nature it's not that we lose it
but
there comes thoughts
we we connect
with something else instead instead if
we just connect to ourselves
everything else is seen through that
through the first person so everything
else is just you just consciousness
when we interact
based on second and third persons we
always interact pretty much in a world
of names and forms but when we interact
from this place of just being
we don't interact with anything else
other than ourselves because you don't
perceive external objects right
so could you would you say it's an
interaction from the formlessness from
the underlying
unity
no the formless doesn't do anything
consciousness doesn't move
only ego moves and really spirituality
is about complete destruction of the ego
but that doesn't happen until it's full
surrender which the ego never wants
so that's why self-inquiry for example
is like um
um
it's not it's not attending to the ego
okay we don't want to steal the mind we
don't care how many thoughts arise we
just attend to ourselves an ego
disappears
okay so
basically so this this surrender or or
or just remaining just as consciousness
implies destruction of what we think you
are to remain as we are if it makes
sense somewhere
right so you did just say cessation of
movement right
complete cessation of movement which is
just in thoughts really
only thoughts moves
move nothing else moves
right
you're thinking
right and then there's a not thinking
yeah
i just say there's a possibility to stay
completely without thinking
right
yes
just like in deep sleep you have no
thoughts you can stay completely
thoughtless right but that opens only
when you don't connect to objects
because if you experience just yourself
and you just settle as that you don't
feel like going towards anything else
and whatever happens good or bad
it's not on you good or bad because you
have no thoughts of good or bad right so
whatever comes because someone might ask
like well you still gotta live in a
world you still gotta do this you still
gotta do that
whatever comes it just comes how it
comes you don't move
right but when you look from this
perspective of the first person
neither do you really see something that
comes and goes since you just see
yourself
right or consciousness
right
so it is from thoughtlessness
whatever no
no no no no no thoughtlessness is a
byproduct of consciousness of just
consciousness
so just like like we mentioned before
consciousness doesn't move
consciousness doesn't care about
anyone's lives consciousness doesn't
care who dies or who's born
consciousness doesn't care about what's
good or bad consciousness doesn't care
about anything that is actually included
in the ego doesn't recognize an ego
so that's why the ego itself the
sufferer and the enjoyer
comes to a point where it sees this
mechanism is just suffering and clinging
on to anything else outside of ourselves
brings the suffering as much as
excitement as it brings at first in the
end it's just it either creates
dependency or it creates somehow like
fear sadness whatever the [ __ ] it may be
and it comes to a point where you just
wish complete destruction of yourself
which sounds like a paradox because
nothing gets destroyed
but somehow it's a it's a good it's a
good it's i i would say the best way of
uh for me at least is the best way of
putting it this way just the complete
destruction of yourself right
whatever your assumption of uh
form and name
uh and destruction of that into
whatever is the force that sort of uh
is prior to that that gives rise to that
to to everything
i'm noticing there's something
interesting about um
thinking again
well there's there's just something
interesting about the way that this
plays with itself
well the way that it
again you're thinking
well there's just all these different
ways that it expresses itself
what expressed is it so
the inexpressible
the what the inexpressible that's
underneath of all this the
incomprehensible that is
principle doesn't express in any way it
doesn't do anything it doesn't move it's
still well even stillness would imply
somehow the absence of movement and it's
not even that but it simply is it
doesn't do anything
if you think consciousness is the one
like expressing and doing things it's
not that
consciousness doesn't move doesn't do
anything
it's not
more a lot of people
expressing in different ways there's no
such thing right
right
yeah it it feels like there's
there's something
like
yeah go ahead go ahead yeah i just want
to point to the fact the fact when we
talk now
yeah
what what brings all these these um
theories and all these
um
confusion
so on and so because in this spiritual
world that there are a lot of things and
a lot of theories
which which make no sense and not only
that we um we usually just get
distracted and just
play and express it but we don't observe
when we think and that's why all these
things come into existence right and we
think we think when we don't stay as
consciousness if we stay as
consciousness we don't think
consciousness doesn't do anything
right
though
what i was uh commenting on was about
how
different um
there's there's the appearance of
different expressions of consciousness
expressing to itself how to be itself
and you seem to have a
a way of doing that that is different
than many of the other sort of
um
expressions of that online like you just
you have a different way of going about
it that's all that i was throwing
normal people it's just people there's
just people on the podcast people
i'm not afraid of using i don't want to
be correct spiritually correct non-dual
correct
people talking people
talking different things acting in
different ways i would i want to say
this because consciousness doesn't do
anything at all
just for that just for that but yes it's
different what i'm talking about and i'm
not seeing it in the like
jesus christ what i haven't you guys
don't no no no no it's different it's
different
when you catch the i thought that rises
and clings on to the world of objects
and projects its own suffering just to
get out of it
and just pointing out to the fact that
this i thought can subside completely
and when it subsides is just vanishes
and what remains is just awareness
but until that
the only way possible and this this is
what buddha did
under the tree this is what jesus did
when he said about the kingdom of god is
within you this is what ramana maharshi
talks about even more clear than those
two
talking about the consciousness that is
in the absence of the i thought because
it's not a thought consciousness is not
a thought
but it's not something you can point at
because the moment
the moment
you
move towards yourselves you disappear
and there's no movement and what remains
is just yourself right
yeah
so it's all in this thinking it's all in
this in these projections of the ego
and staying in this sphere
of uh expressions of this and that
just just prolongs prolonged
spirituality prolongs non-duality
prolongs everything just because we
don't see
the eye that has risen because we're not
accustomed to be aware
first of all be aware not to mention
aware of ourselves because even if
you're aware
at least a little about the present
moment
you can get somehow of a taste that this
mind can stop
but it's just a help in a way just to
show you but when you really attend
when your vision is turned inwards
and you just remain at your own source
no thinking is possible because there's
nothing that rises just like in the
moment before waking up
you have a split second
when it's just consciousness but then
immediately the eye thought rises and
it's you that woke up and you that has
this body and you live in the world and
so on
without that is just consciousness
yeah what i'm alluding to is uh
like like an acclimation of sorts to
um the way that
um
it's hinted at or that it's uh
that
the ex the cut cutting through is being
shared let's say
uh unwinding how unwinding the knot is
being shared there's sort of like a
period of acclimation because
yeah you seem to have a very uh
a distinct style or way of of
approaching this
um
and
i think i think it's beautiful each each
sort of way that um it is um
shared
but yeah you have a distinct way of
let's say of of uh
slowing someone down until they
recognize how they are thinking
basically and so that they can see them
for themselves how to cut through how to
untangle that knot that's what i'm
getting at
yeah just now when you talked
just now when you talk maybe you will
watch the replay
for like 20 seconds
you you lost you lost contact and went
into thinking and if you watch the
replay you'll see why
it's very interesting i don't want to
say it but it's very interesting if you
would watch the replay and see and this
is what happens with most of the
speakers on the internet
they don't realize that what they're
saying
comes from thinking not from their
actual experience
i'm not saying now maybe if you don't
acknowledge yourself as enlightened or
or awakened or whatever you know it
doesn't even freaking matter it's a
freaking joke really
but i'm saying i'm saying
if it's not direct if it's not direct
it leaves room open for interpretation
it leaves room open for thinking which
is exactly what all the scriptures all
the spirituality all the non-duality
points at
is to stop the mind com not even a
single thought not even a single thought
not even a sin because
the only thought that can remain it
would be the eye thought which is at the
base of every other thoughts
but it can't because when you're not
aware of the world of objects you're not
aware of the world of thoughts the world
of emotions and everything else
if it focuses itself it disappears
completely you can't see it can stay
it's go it's a ghost it's not real the
ego is a ghost
but by name and form it catches name and
form too it's the same i
that now
it can be a suffering person
and a moment later it can be pure
without any adjuncts it's that simple
so it's interesting i like i'm not
really watching you or anyone else but
when i talk is very when we talk is very
easy when you lose yourself but i i'm
wondering by the end of the of the video
that we're making if you notice how you
lose yourself
do you have an idea
what would you see
yeah just
just leaving
non-movement
basically
yes yes yes yes yes
but it's very subtle it's very subtle
when the eye rises and if you cat that
this is what if you have red um
have you heard of it
yeah
when janaka said
he finally caught the teeth
the eye that was rising he finally cut
it he cut the point where it rises
and that's that's that's the brilliant
thing because you don't really have to
do anything
outside of just being yourself but the
moment you catch the eye thought
that's really brilliant that's really
brilliant
because it's very it's it's it's it's a
long long long habit
right i was just about to say that
yeah it's a strong pattern
yeah
wanting to leave into movement of some
sort repeatedly
yep
sort of staying in non-movement is
feels like a new pattern that's learned
in a way
you have to think
you have to think to say this yeah
basically yes
yes yes yes but it can be your own
experience you're that
yeah that's the beauty of it
right
right
right
do you talk about training and
concentration
no no no well
uh it's it's more uh if you would say if
you would say um
in a way it isn't
it is concentration
but being at concentration upon yourself
immediately the one that concentrates
disappears so it's not really
concentration the moment you start
actually and correctly inquire
it's immediately being that's why i
can't say it's a practice and if it's if
it's taken like really really really
good
and you gotta you you got somehow at
least a mental understanding out of it
or even better you started noticing when
the eye thought rises
it's very cool because because you can't
see it as a concentration because
concentration is from the point of the
ego i gotta concentrate i gotta be more
like this i gotta be more like that but
if the ego
admits openly that
suffering it it all it's all that it
knows and it attains to its own
destruction
that's immediate
call it enlightenment call it what it is
but it's short it's short if it's if
it's not done again and again and again
until it is complete
but even by this process you'll see that
you have less and less thoughts
but i can't say it's concentration if
some people are like well self-inquiry i
gotta do it i gotta they think it's
about concentration but it's about
taking up taking a very great
opportunity to actually know yourself by
being yourself
do you describe yourself as anything or
not
you can't really describe yourself
because you would have to look at
yourself to describe yourself and since
it's just you you can't really describe
yourself
but but for sure you can see something
um very obvious that you always are
and and as much as you think like you're
the traveler in all the three states of
consciousness
and you have all these bodies and you
have all these memories and everything
else
by what i'm saying you can see that the
states of consciousness because that's
why they are called states of
consciousness
you know they happen within you
all the states of everything the whole
world happens within you without your
awareness without you as awareness the
world can be seen
how can you see the world now without
being aware of it really
how can you notice in deep sleep that
that that you had no dreams if you
weren't there
how would you how would you um
talk about
your dreams in the morning if you were
not there to witness the dreams we we
always see seeing is permanent it's 24
7. the problem is that it gets lost and
mixed with objects that's the only
problem
do you ever also call yourself your
thoughts or the objects
what do you see
do you ever also refer to yourself as
the thoughts and the objects
you can't refer to yourself as thoughts
and objects since you are the one being
aware of thoughts and objects
thoughts happen outside of you you're
aware of them
subject objects
subject object and everything else you
can perceive it's outside of you
including the body
including the mind
whatever can be witnessed is not you
but then when you remain as the ultimate
witness or as the seer or whatever it is
or just as seeing because really there's
no seer there's no subject
there's no comment about thoughts
because you have no thoughts
and there's no comment about objects
because you don't see objects
that's why jesus said very beautiful
remain in the world but don't remain as
part of it
see at least from these texts maybe he
didn't say it but but it's very cool
what i read in these texts
because this can be everyone's
experience you can still live in a world
but you're completely not of it how can
you be since the world happens within
you
if if the world
is there
second before you as awareness to
witness it
so do you feel
that awareness and world are separate
different
no no it's it well let me put it this
way
if i have to explain it
i have to separate
just for the for the sake of explanation
i i i i
i see right yeah yeah because
you read them as non-separate and then
when you do explain you explain them as
separate to help shift more away from
world to okay
because then there's no point of a world
since it's just you
if you focus on yourself
and manage to remain there without
movement without anything without going
outside that which goes outside
disappears and it takes no ownership of
a world of a body or object so how can
you talk about anything since you just
perceive yourself
nice
do you talk about the stillness as a
perfection or anything like
that well you are perfection yes you can
say it's it's perfection in a way that
you have no lack you have no need since
you always are what we desire and what
we want is always in the future it's
always as a next opportunity what i'm
talking about it's an all
present opportunity
it's not in the future it always is
and it's brilliant because it is
perfection in the sense that it doesn't
matter how much the body can be beaten
up it doesn't matter how much the mind
can get exhausted it doesn't matter how
much
whatever else happens in the world
you can't be affected it's impossible
we just imagine that we suffer
our suffering is our own responsibility
for attending to something which we're
not
if we don't attend to that we have no
thoughts if we have no thoughts it's
just peace
if it's peace and sight how can it not
be peace outside you but then you don't
really see peace inside or outside it's
just peace
so in a way you can say it's perfection
from this point of view because
it's unaffected man
you just like we see when we wake up
that dreams have not affected us and we
just imagined all that crap it's the
same with what we called real life
we think we suffer
just so in the end we can freaking wake
up at one point to see that it's like we
were in a freaking corner being afraid
of our own projections
and yes i would say this is
very much
necessary
to remain at at least at first to make
the difference between what's real and
what's unreal right
yeah so there's a a knot that gets
unwinded through that process
what do you mean by unwanted unwanted is
that unwinded like another
yes yes yes yes so
when we sleep when we sleep and we have
no dreams there's no such thing as a
knot
because we're not aware of objects
but when we wake up with breathing we
don't wake up it's just ego that wakes
up that's the knot what wakes up and
goes back to sleep
what we are doesn't wake up doesn't go
back to sleep
so that's why
self-attention or self-awareness
focuses on that which wakes up and goes
back to sleep just so we see that we
never wake up and we never go back to
sleep
because if that thing which the moment
it's sought for disappears
what remains is just the peace that was
in deep sleep the same consciousness
that was just aware of itself but from
the point of view of a person or an
individual that identifies with the body
and all it's know all it knows is just
just this
i thought i i body consciousness
he thinks
he was absent in deep sleep but it's not
true it's just because you woke up in
the morning again as that which went to
sleep and it's the same identification
which brings the same hindrances
but you you had to be in deep sleep to
witness
that there was absolutely no content
there
yeah i'm finding it interesting that
you're
pointing to ramana and the
untangling or unwinding of the i thought
as uh
as a pinnacle of
of how to the how basically the how
because that's what people ask they ask
how
the only way
there's no other way because
as much as you search in objects
the out of this habit of searching in
objects you you know like you know the
karma you know it's not really what we
think karma is it's it it's all in our
mental tendencies
so if we search in objects okay where we
meditate on objects we just prolong this
habit of attending to objects
but the ego is the problem not the
object the object is neutral it's
insanity it has no business with us
so it doesn't matter you can meditate on
an outward god you can meditate on on
all kinds of meditations until you
attend to the meditator
to actually subside for the possibility
of meditation there can be a meditation
because meditation on object in the end
would be just focusing
what i'm talking about is a completely
unfocused view
which may sound weird it comes by
focusing the subject but it's immediate
when it's done it's being
so
our only duty
is just to be aware
of ourselves as we are
but if it happens that we have
tendencies
of rising as he goes
immediately we gotta reverse back to our
attention
and then there's no ego
and i like ramana because it took me
years a lot of years
very few people can understand him
because it really requires practice
and that's why it gets self-inquiry it's
misunderstood it's all about
self-attention it's not about asking
like a madman who who am i who am i or
finding the place where the thoughts
arise like it's some place outside of
ourselves or some mystical place
uh
doesn't matter where
you know
you really
have to study it
to at one point be able to practice
correctly
and ramana from my perspective at least
i haven't found or seen a man that
explained it
well
uh or better than him
he explained it very very clear
and just because he explained
that everything that can be perceived
is an obstacle
what else
do we remain with
other than ourselves
that's where we find liberation that's
where we find freedom that's where we
find peace
a lot of a lot of people think
it's about a state of enlightenment it's
about awakening to some what nature
being rich being successful but dude in
deep sleep
we're none of that
and we're happy
we're peaceful
it's a different kind of happiness
because it's resting and when you don't
take yourself to be the body and you
rest as consciousness the body is able
to rest too but you know why i don't see
or don't say the body sleeps because
there's no one in the body that's
sleeping
the body just rests naturally
if there's a sleeper there yes the body
sleeps
but the body doesn't sleeps the body
doesn't say
uh i woke up or i go back to sleep it's
only the ego which says all this crap
so it's not really about achieving
something it's about settling as what we
are
resting as what we are in it
is very it's very
simple
but it's hard in a way because very few
are able to stick
just to the subject because the mind may
be very agitated very anxious and you
only always want to find something to
cling on and you'll get an object to
meditate upon but it just makes your
concentration
better towards objects concentration
towards yourself
is impossible because what remains is
just beingness
and that has no
it has nothing to it
right so first you point to a duality
you create a duality to help recognize
stillness and then after recognizing
stillness
then stillness and movement are
equivalent
no no no well just as an explanation
self-attention itself gets rid of
duality immediately
it's just the explanation to actually
hear and understand correctly what you
have to do because some people find the
eye thought in the body some people find
it an emptiness some people find it in
different things and they think they
inquire correctly
while they are still attending to other
things and they they wonder why
self-inquiry doesn't work correctly it's
because you fold yourself into feelings
and sensations
taking yourself to the eye and it's in a
way understandable
because thoughts are one thing physical
objects are one thing but emotions are
deeper that's why when we feel anxious
we feel sad we feel lonely it affects us
very deep when we have thoughts it's not
that bad somehow you can get rid of them
but an emotion it's a little harder
or a feeling or yeah something else
so do you describe that i thought as
sensation
no no no no it's not a sensation
because the moment
the i thought
attends
to itself it disappears it's not real it
doesn't exist
it has no substance
it's not made of anything you just
thought if you describe it as a
projection
you can't really i would say a
projection is when the subject
hallucinates
right but when the subject is focused
there is no pre i would say let let me
put it this way it's not the project the
projection is the projector
and just like the projector projects
like you have the the you know that uh
the screen the screen and the moon you
might have heard it
okay we have the projector which is the
mind that projects on the screen of
consciousness a movie
the moment we stop attending to our own
projections
okay and we attend to the screen
immediately by turning off the projector
that's
that's immediate that's immediate
consciousness when the projector
attends to itself what remains is only
the screen because it gets turned off
so in your one-on-ones and whatnot you
treat moments of
stillness and peace like this as
the person
sort of
figuring out what they are resting as
they are
if i'm figuring in one-on-ones
what did you say in your one-on-ones
that you have when the person sort of
stills themselves and like is able to
just be as they are with you presently
do you find that to be like their
progress do they usually report that as
their progress
well um
progress can be religious for the ego or
realization do they report that as their
realization do you
no if they say if anyone tells me that
somehow they realize something or they
get closer they're still in their own
projection it's just their thoughts
in my one-on-ones the best i can do is
simply point to the fact that you don't
have to look at the world you don't have
to look at anything
that comes
by the outside and it's something you
can focus on and and that's actually the
reason of suffering
okay your own projections and the moment
you just remain still and know that you
are god as this i am principle the
moment you focus on this i am
your projections disappear with the
world with everything else
so when they manage somehow
to unfocus the world and just focus
themselves
they experience yes what they are but
the problem is
out of this tendencies to again
rise to again rise to again rise
some might think it's a practice just
because the ego is there to say it's a
practice or it's a progress or it's
whatever it is
but the same thing has to be done again
all over
and and really it's not a problem of
realizing the goal because the goal
really exists before any type of goal
the goal is
is not somewhere in the future
but the only the only thing
that that's useful it's actually knowing
how to do it properly so then you don't
need other goals because
any goal comes as thought
so in a way it's not really much to say
about it but that's why it's beautiful
you won't be there to say anything about
it
right since you remain at that what can
you really say about it
how can you describe yourself there are
a lot of words
omnipresence omnipotent omnidis omnidax
beyond the worlds without but it's
really more simple than that because
from the ego's perspective it seems like
something
to fantasize about
no no no it's very simple
it's very very simple
there's no distinction to draw there's
no
measurement to make
it's just
what it is
as it is
well well well well let me put it this
way someone say it is what it is or just
what is
they refer to thoughts emotions feelings
objects so on and so forth i'm not
referring to that
when i say what is
is consciousness
and it is as it is because it can be
other way it doesn't modify
it doesn't come it doesn't go it always
is as it is
but i want to make this distinction
because some speakers or teachers or
whatever they say
this is all that is the moving cars the
window the heat the sensations the
anxiety the confusion no no no no no
that's not what it is
that's absent when you sleep
it's completely absent
so we don't have to settle for less we
don't have to let to settle for
um what comes and goes i would say what
is
is that which means
while awake deep sleep while awake
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yes
yes yes yes yes
yes
but then if deep sleep is brought upon
wakefulness then there are not two
states
you know
it's not even a state
because if consciousness is all there is
and you remain as that what state are
you there to move in
because only the traveler only the ego
moves from one state of consciousness to
another
um
so you're finding your experience to be
something like
deep sleep and then some sort of eating
or talking or
like some sort of a mixture of of those
uh
because you know how
how babies um
how babies eat
from their their mother's breast
it's like
they eat
but at the same time
they're not they're not aware of the
action of eating
they're not aware
of of what the body is doing
or or or
or or thinking now this is me this is my
mom i'm getting fed and i'm
no hunger no this no that you know he's
just like a sleeping baby
that gets fed
that moves that does um
you know jesus said something beautiful
only those who are innocent like kids
can enter the kingdom of god which is
very cool because he wasn't pointing at
an innocence like like pretending to be
a kid without responsibilities without
no no no it's the innocence
of your own or intimacy of your own
consciousness that is not
dirty with thoughts yet
so you're not thinking
and when you're not thinking and you
remain just as that
you're not of the world and whatever
happens in the world
it happens to the body
but since you're not the body
you can say it happens to you
and whatever you do you eat you sleep
you walk you work you
you don't move
just like the baby that sleeps while
it's being fed
and is not aware of being fed in the
same way you're not aware of other
things other than yourself
and it's beautiful because you don't
feel separation
and that's why i love about ramana
maharshi and the authentic spirituality
that still can be found
in the indian scriptures for example
is because dude they talk about satchit
ananda
existence consciousness bliss bliss why
bliss
white bliss
because it's in our own nature to feel
blissful but not in the way we think has
excitement it's peace and this is what
has been lost
in this new age spirituality and a lot
of crap we just feed which just feeds
the ego
what these people do talk about it's
real
it's an actual experience
but but when i see experience some
imagine as something you'll get or
no no no no no with the experience of
what you are
in each moment without thought
without objects we really can take this
great opportunity to know ourselves or
just be ourselves
yeah
do you use the or suggest using the
breath as a way to be yourself or to
know yourself or rest as yours
you don't
well breath
is outside of you
breath is still an object doesn't matter
how so it yes it's more subtle than
the body
but
it's still substance doesn't matter if
it's more subtle
by focusing on breath you're still
focusing on something
are you aware of your breath in deep
sleep
no
yeah exactly
no one is
so that's the the easiest way is the
easiest way
and this this can can bring a good
understanding that
how deep sleep is
peaceful without worries without objects
without anything including the subject
itself
that we should realize
that the difference between deep sleep
and wakefulness is just us
rising
as an eye as an ego connecting
to our own projections by attending
objects
so it's just about the eye which is
absent in deep sleep as the ego so why
go about breath why go about
i don't know
mantras words gods
uh
statues or chakras or anything else
if the eye that connects to all this
crap is the only issue
it's very obvious when we say i feel bad
or i feel anxious
it's very obvious that it's us
experiencing anxiety
sadness or or anything else but we
experience it because of some thought
or because of some physical object
without that we're at peace
whatever happens to us
that's the coolest thing
real spirituality
makes you responsible for your own
misery
makes you responsible for everything
because we clearly see we cause our own
[ __ ] by thinking
immediately jealousy arises if we think
of our girlfriend as an object and
someone uses our object which we take
our home someone is going into our home
and we don't like that and we become
jealous or possessive
you know
someone uses our car
or the thought even of someone using our
car
that's me
that's me what identified with
as i the car the apartment the girl this
that it's all [ __ ] suffering as much
as much bliss as we think it gives us
nah
nah
now
everything that the ego is made of it's
outside of it
and it seems solid
as much as it maintains this
relationship
so it doesn't matter if the ego takes
foreign form of the worker
it doesn't matter if it takes the form
of a
families
or the shopper or the
sufferer or the enjoyer or even the
meditator
[ __ ] it still takes a forward man
so even these formal
objective meditations it's still to keep
the meditator on
yeah it's really miserable to weave
one's identity into so many objects
well the idea
the identity is the objects that's the
problem
the identity is made up just out of
objects just like this
without me thinking i'm a boyfriend
okay so without thinking i'm a boyfriend
i would have to not
attend
to the object which i named my
girlfriend which is my
mind you know without the object
girlfriend
there can't be me as
the boyfriend
without the object work there can be me
as the worker without the object i don't
know
poor without the out the the absence of
money worth or in this case you're poor
just because you desire money as thought
that that's maybe the difference between
someone poor
and someone rich the rich
doesn't need to think about money it
hasn't in its hand but the poor one
thinks about the money as an object both
have money
one has it in its mind what has it in
its hand but both are in the mind
actually
that's why it doesn't matter how much
money you have
you're the rich one
when the money makes you when the
objects makes the subject the rich
but then you still suffer it doesn't
matter how much money you have
the identity is the problem really not
the objects what i'm talking because the
the money doesn't say
uh
or that doesn't say anything nothing
says anything
just the ego has pros and cons
compares associates so on and so forth
so even if you have money if you have a
house if you have a girlfriend
just because you have and stabilizes an
identity
it makes you miserable
so living without identity i'm not
saying you won't function
you can still go to your job you can
still eat
you can still [ __ ]
you can still take care of your kids you
can still do whatever you want
but you function
differently
since you remain at that which always is
awareness and what the body does
is what the body does it's none of our
business
what are you thinking
i'm just relaxed
you relax
yeah
that's good
so you have no thoughts
right
it feels really good
no need to move
you can more clearly see the subtle
urge
of uh
there's still something to
get there's still something to find
there's still something to write down
there's still something to share
there's still still some wisdom to
attain or to distill into a book
whatever
can i ask you when you talk where are
you looking
into some projection of a story
okay okay okay very good
okay
you know how in in
when um
there's this uh
um phenomena
um rapid eye movement
why why why
when we dream
our eyes move fast
because we project the reality
in the same way
in wakefulness
we're dreaming
looking who the [ __ ] knows where
without looking
deep into ourselves
when there is no projection but it's
just peace
all right
[Laughter]
um
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
um
are you also familiar with the trinity
model and the orthodox christianity
oh i come from a from an
orthodox christian background
right yeah
yeah
similarly
do you feel like
that
is the father do you feel like that
that is the father one
alex where are you looking
right
all right
what was with the father what's with the
father
nothing
nothing there's nothing
it's just another way of
putting it
but
yeah it's just another way it's just
another story another way of putting it
yeah
well you can make like somehow a
beautiful analogy
like uh you know
the sun
right with the without without the holy
ghost can't really remain one with the
father
so so
uh
yeah when it receives the holy ghost or
whatever it's one the father and i are
one
you know
the fresh breath of the [ __ ] spirit
[Laughter]
that's a good one with the rapid eye
movement
dream projection
pretty good alex watch
i haven't watched in the videos on your
channel
but i bet
if you watch carefully
most the people you have interviewed or
even those that
talk about truth
i say it's very rare and i'm not i'm not
saying it just because it's my
experience but it's very obvious when
someone knows what it's talking about
because
the eyes they say the windows the window
to our soul right
if it's clean
where can it move
to something which comes and goes but
then it's not clean
have you seen babies
like
four months five months
look how they look it's pure perception
no thoughts
that's the state in which we should be
all day long and we can still function
it's no problem we can still i guarantee
you and you function better
because the lens are clear you're not
looking with the glasses outside you're
looking [ __ ] inward
but yeah just like those
that's and i i i wanna i wanna make a
point to this
because many get confused
just like the babies just like the
animals
that are just remaining as
perception
we can remain as that pure perception we
don't have to chase thoughts
the father brings everything we need
we don't need anything else
you know that's complete faith abiding
as pure perception not having faith in
an outward god
you know
because then if we need faith for an
outward god then we're not we have not
surrendered completely
but many people that talk about it they
don't know what they're talking about
because they're thinking
it's very cool to see
that when you remain as this beautiful
presence and you guys can search
watch show show
watch ramana maharishi's eyes you can
find videos with him on youtube you
might see his head moving like this
you know because he was [ __ ]
overwhelmed by this power of the self
but his eyes don't move man
they remain just like in deep sleep open
somewhat someone's eyes in deep sleep
you'll see they don't move
open someone's eyes when they dream
[Laughter]
and open up someone's eyes
that dreams in their sleep all their
life
that's the beauty when you when you
when you open your eyes for the first
time from the inside
the the eyes will just reflect your
state but when you open your eyes from
the inside
the baby the fresh baby seems to be
doing something that's
between the two where it's both a deep
sleep and uh
like bouncing like
understanding the dream
beginning to understand the dream well
the baby when the baby looks they they
don't have the vision formed until like
six months or something like that
and when the baby until it's like six
months it can't vocalize objects
so it's somehow in an unfocused view
you know
so the baby doesn't perceive yet the
world
when it's young it doesn't see the world
outside of itself
but of course
the moment thought is learned the moment
creation is foreign you know because uh
in the bible because we talk a little
bit about christianity
you know the formation of the world the
gods make the world in the six days and
the seventh day
he rested
i would say the seventh day
should be the first day which symbolizes
the uncreated god right
and i would say the other six days
is just the creation of the eagle with
the world
the the
the sabbath is the root and then the six
days are
dream of all sort
yeah
anything really about because i i swear
we are brainwashed by fake spirituality
there is
real spirituality within ourselves man
it is there and it's waiting only for
those earnest seekers
that really really strive towards it
but just like like like you can't come
into the kingdom of god unless you're
innocent like a child
you can't attend to this
pearl to this treasure you can't dive in
deep
to actually get it if you're still there
right that's why when you inquire you
disappear and that's when the pearl
shines right you know what why they say
the self or or god is is is self shining
it doesn't need something else to prove
that it is it's it's quite different
when we are not there to search for it
in objects it reveals itself because
we're not there to obstruct our own view
right
it seems to be a part of the game
all of that noise
and only that little bit of signal
and
really seeking through all the hay to
find the needles
seems to be an important part of the
game
it seems so it seems so
and well in a sense that you
alluded to being so powerful and
important
anytime there's a little bit of a sense
of self that wants to hijack its
realization and just go and
it's not that
well that's that's why uh ramana is so
is so majestic from my perspective of
course it doesn't have to be that way
for everyone
he helps us cut
all the seeking in the hay
and then we remember that the needle is
in our pocket
that's why it's hard finding it in the a
we have it in our pocket we just got to
search
in our pocket not in the
you know
and really truly feel the needle all
over in the pocket
well dude it's
this is not something that i have where
anyone else had everyone is this
everyone right and
really there are no waters
all sentience is it
is
because when you remain as that
when you remain just as this
principle of i am well it's i am it
points to i
okay
it points
to me
and m is just
beingness
i am the beingness
it doesn't then we don't talk about
other sentient beings
this is the core of the creation this is
the uncreated light of the collated
uh orthodox spirituality
orthodox christianity the uncreated
light
the core of all creation
well if it's just god
it makes sense that the creation it's
god itself
you know but we can't know ourselves as
god if we're searching the creation
because we're gonna be lost in it
basically we gotta strive towards that
which
can be seen
it can be really found
but it's our own experience
and then we can talk really about
creation since we can see separation we
can see duality
really feeling this needle
all over um
oh it's your own experience man you
should you should you should be totally
in that yeah
you know how people think um
oneness is the gathering of all things
you know like everything's oneness like
our emotions our feelings are the
objects we see the thoughts everything
else that's oneness
that's basically
saying
creation
is one
which is false we can see that the
thought is different from the car the
car is different from our mother our
mother is different from the horse
you can't really find oneness in the
creation
you find god
or if that's what you want to find you
know god or what we are
you find it within yourself and then you
can but you can't say it's oneness since
it's just one
some people excuse just like
i did
a lot of times when i was seeking
i thought i got to see oneness as
everything
is the same thing no no
we see or perceive
what true oneness but i i don't like
really saying oneness we we remain as
one
when we stop attending to
whatever else is there it doesn't matter
if we say it's real and real if we make
it as oneness it's really freaking
futile to find anything there because
it's still the subject
making or imagining everything as one we
gotta cut off all the imagination
it can't be there because if there's
imagination we'll imagine oneness to be
a lot of things
coming together
world peace humans holding hands
animals not being slaughtered so on and
so forth like
like a picture of oneness and gratitude
in heaven
it's not like that each one is
responsible it doesn't matter how life
is
we are we are responsible not god not
our neighbor not
we are responsible
for
our ego that rises just like we're
responsible
for our own true nature
one of those it can it can it can be
simultaneously that's why it can't be a
oneness
the simple fact that we point at
to the window to the door to this to
that to
whatever and just we try to make the
theory out of it and saying all is god
with me
we move the whole point of god that
abide that right here we're attending to
the needle or attending to the hay
yeah yeah yeah and you can't find the
needle in the hay
that's why it's so hard
right
that's why rumi said going from room to
room looking for the diamond that's
around the neck
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
and that's why the spiritual search
seems like we're trying to find the
needle in the a
right because it's so [ __ ] hard
trying to find with our own awareness
the object which we think will bring us
the realization
we're trying to find something which is
not now
in the hay in the future by recollecting
the past to search better for a separate
experience than this
right but i'm not pointing now to the
experience of sitting in the chair or
talking no no no no no
awareness awareness awareness
we're always aware
but the moment we're aware of our own
awareness there's not you want to be
aware of the other it's just awareness
right
yeah
that's that's the needle that's
yeah
we found the needle we found the needle
we were holding it
it just wasn't a separate person that
was holding some awareness it was
awareness itself that was holding itself
what do you mean
it wasn't a separate person that
was finding
the needle and
awareness is the needle
it is it is itself
yes
it's like the needle trying to find
itself in the hay you know
it's basically impossible it can't be an
experience
that is not now it's impossible it's
that's why it's it's it's these this
this freaking funny stories of people
going to the peaks of the himalayas to
get initiated
in
kriya yoga fighting babaji you know
because the ego
the the more it searches the more it
tries to find the stronger it gets
the bigger is the goal
the more it's fulfilling or set it or it
thinks the more satisfied and fulfilled
it will be
but dude when you go from your apartment
to the peaks of the himalayas
awareness
is in your apartment and awareness is
there
or better said
your apartment is in awareness himalayas
are in awareness too otherwise you
couldn't be aware of them
yeah so that's why we don't need to
leave
we don't need to go anywhere else
other than towards our own self
because even those masters if they are
for real
they'll have to point towards you
how can truth be somewhere else
how can truth be cultivated
you can say yes you cultivated it in a
way that ego loses its grip more and
more and more and more on objects and
and attends to itself yes you can see
you cultivate the right knowledge to
stop focusing on other things but then
from it's it's from the perspective of
the ego that you're getting better
consciousness doesn't say anything
consciousness doesn't move
consciousness doesn't give a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and that's why it's beautiful
we are the only ones responsible
i love that about
the room is
in awareness and the himalayas are in
awareness the book is an awareness
yes
yes
a video of the video of theo talking is
an awareness
yes yes
and the viewers that will watch this
video if it's going to be posted at one
point
the video
is in their awareness
they are watching
the video
and they think it's outside
but the moment they attend themselves
they'll see that the video is within the
whole freaking physical reality is
mental
and when the mental
vanishes
there is not even a mental is just you
but until then
everything
whatever happens
happens with you within you so even
those books that we read
to get somewhere or understand what
awareness is happens by our awareness
[Laughter]
yeah i'm gonna
i'm gonna project out on wholeness and
then i'm gonna
find
play the game of
finding
it
um in what i always was through some
sort of a deconstruction of my own
projection of illusion
of unwholeness
well
even if you wanted to construct your
reality how would you do it
see where i'm projecting
the needs for something other than this
what do you
what do you mean by that
like i i like like i wanna i wanna
understand somehow like the impulse or
the need for something other than the
needle that is already
that would be the
deconstructing of that impulse or the
need for something other than what is
okay but how did the construction takes
place
right
like this is very important because the
only way
it can die off it's the with the ego
that projects right so it's all with one
way ticket towards yourself that's the
only way
of course you might hear people with
vidpasana or other crap deconstructing
realities they're just imagining man
because they're attending two objects to
deconstruct them and this happens within
their own illusion of being a separate
self
and this is just an example there are
plenty of plenty of examples
[Laughter]
wouldn't it be weird if if all these
sages
were saying uh different things pointing
to the same truth it would be weird
but i say most of them are wrongly
misunderstood
either by their first disciples that
didn't understand them or by
just people that write about them and we
get this understanding of the
constructing reality
from a separate
self from the ego the ego trying to
deconstruct its own [ __ ] how can it
do so it's impossible
it's constantly creating even the
feeling of deconstructing a reality
right
laughs
[Laughter]
you
[Laughter]
deo how old are you
20
are you
i'm third i'm turning 30 soon yeah
are you traveling mostly or do you have
a place that you usually stay for more
of the time
oh yeah yeah yeah
i i i stay in romania in bucharest
but i i'm traveling
whenever people uh
request
when there are let's say in germany
right they gather 10 people they i get
the same messages i'll do an event then
and i'll travel or
or go for a period of time like now i'm
i'm going uh i'm going to canada
uh to make an event to
or or i'll go after maybe to uk only in
that sense i'm traveling otherwise i
don't really travel
okay you just stay at home a lot
yeah
yeah
this is my iphone
[Laughter]
what did you say
this is my ashram right right i'm just
kidding i'm just kidding i'm just
kidding
uh were you born there
no no no no no in galat it's a different
city
but in romania though
yeah yeah yeah
and raised there your whole life
yeah
do you did you raise my mom and dad
yeah
well i i remain with my with my
grandparents most of my childhood
because they must move to bucharest and
i remain there
did you have brothers and sisters
no
only child
yeah
did you feel like there was something
missing that you wanted to find all the
time all the time
when you were young like
yeah yeah um
when i was young i was running outside
well
it's not it's not that childhood that
you have in the cities
um it's more that countryside childhood
you know
even though it's in a city it's it's
it's more like like free
running on garages
at eight you stay until 11 or 12
you know
at night you your your grandparents come
with like a big stick to
run
towards you to go back home trying to
find you in the neighborhood
and all that crap you get in to fight
you you know that kind of childhood but
but i had moments
where i would go go i was i
i would remain
it was very weird i would run with my
friends outside even when running
even when doing activities i would black
out for 30 minutes
and then i would come back and didn't
know what happened for 30 minutes
but i didn't ask people because somehow
i didn't feel the need to because i was
still in the right place with them no
one said anything so i guess the
questions weren't raised but it was a
little weird but at the same time i
couldn't get preoccupied about it
because it didn't happen like on a
regular basis it happened from time to
time you know
and then uh besides this like like there
were some other some other uh
weird experience how we would call them
and
at 13 when i moved moved to bucharest
or 12 no 12 but at 13
i got myself
my mom was always spiritual and we had
like a big library you know
and
i found some books
like the first book i read
either was what i think it was on the
four noble truths or life of buddha or
something like that
and uh
um
somehow somehow i got my answer there's
still there's something to seek
something to find
but but i thought it's outside that's
the problem you know but i i always felt
something was missing
yeah right but it's not something that's
missing it's
when you are missing
when you're not on your throne when
you're not settled there right
come and take your place and then you're
like [ __ ] you want to get into the
kingdom back you want to get into the
castle
but you you that's the thing you you
you think only when you're on the throne
that you're on the king you're the king
you know
because it's very easy you can get back
your throne by simply shouting and
everyone will respect your orders but
the thing is most people identify just
just just like the bag like a beggar and
forget that they're the king
you know
yeah
so when i when i when i when i
got myself my my hand on on that book
that was the start you can see of a
spiritual journey to somehow
find freedom
because it may even if i was 13 it made
sense like this guy because i was
thinking somehow like this like this guy
has it all
a [ __ ] castle
girls
food
entertainment he'll be king
of
emperor whatever he'll be
but still he's not happy
you know
it makes sense why he leaves to find he
he must he must have
uh
a burning desire for a truth you know
there's something missing and i gotta
find it that it's very obvious
he's been spoiled with everything
and it just makes him more miserable so
he has to find truth well
he could have found it in the castle too
but
like but like it you see
um
it's very hard by attending to the world
you're you're used to
um
to
to find truth because you get distracted
by people by
what you have to do there and someone
you gotta find somehow a sage
but naked in the woods
to tell you
to look within and if not you remain
like buddha under the bodhi tree having
no option left but to look within
it's interesting the stories of
christ in buddha that they're really
taken to the extremes
um
in order for the revelation to be found
within
yes
yes
yes
yes and that's that's why they're
written that way so that you can sort of
recognize quickly that it doesn't matter
how far out you take these stories to
their extremes that you'll always find
what you're looking for within
yeah
yes yes
but but
yeah you just can't you can't
symbolically or archetypically express a
story that's beyond those stories
like that's that's why they're there and
that's why they've lasted thousands of
years
but that's why i love them so much i
love these stories so much
because they bring the authenticity of
spirituality it shows that with dude
without striving
it's impossible it's impossible we got
used to new age spirituality where we're
lazy and we want somehow an outside
truth to come with us
to us
but it's actually different when we're
tired of looking outside even waiting
for the truth to come
then we're able to look within
so those immature seekers
they can't look within it's too many
thoughts too many tendencies too many
habits of looking outside
so that's why
they don't get prepared to look within
they just waste
and waste again
um
all the tendency to work to look towards
objects and they see at one point
that even
meditating on an object doesn't do you
any good
you're still focused
if truth is within
well that within
is not an object
that within
is the subject
right so this the sh
share the duality
to get the recognition of the subject
and then you collapse the duality
wait can you repeat
when someone's seeking you you point to
the needle the subject
yeah
and to to really feel it all over
really
all over and then you can collapse the
duality between the subject and the
object
yes but it makes sense why because
when you're not attending to objects and
you just attend to yourself
the
the objects or or the tendencies to look
towards objects lose grip on yourself
and the more it loses the grip
the more they move further away and you
just remain by yourself and when you
actually remain by yourself you see that
there is no object due to fine it's just
you
because when you look within that which
looks within disappears
and what remains is just the kingdom of
god is just seeing is just being
no person whatsoever yeah
so i would say those who manage somehow
to inquire
which is not really because even what
ramana said you know
uh asking questions who am i and this
and that it's not about receiving an
answer it's just to stabilize
self-attention you move to the object
you don't bother about the object and
you
remember who am i that's the search
where am i not what's that
no no no it's who am i
you reverse to self-attention you go out
again who am i
again
[Music]
when you just remain like this and then
you don't need to ask questions because
you've got the hang of it you understand
what self-attention is you've done it
many times and now you don't need
scriptures you don't need indications
you don't need anything right you just
gotta remain there that's it
yeah
yeah that's a good one is just pointing
the finger
and looking at the point of the finger
no no no no no no no it's looking at
what the finger points that that's yeah
yeah yeah right
one second
yeah important distinction
what do you see important distinction
yeah exactly looking at what the fingers
pointing to
yes
yes
what is it pointing to
yeah
that's simple practice
and stabilizing in that enough to where
you're not reading anymore you're not
looking at you're not seeking anymore
no no no no no if you're still reading
if you're still trying to get inside you
have not understood yet
that i said when you're not anymore
that's what i'm saying
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
somehow we read
and we try to try to contemplate just
just so we're mature enough
to to dive in deep within ourselves
because then when we see
drugs don't help us because he doesn't
help us money doesn't help us even
outward spirituality doesn't help us
right [ __ ] we're left alone very good
very good very good
now spirituality can start get started
alone
right
here no guru can help you no teacher can
help you it's just you
yeah
and we if we listen correctly to what
the outward guru for example says to
look within
we actually see dudes that the guru
calls us from within and it's not
separate from us
he wasn't talking from the body he was
talking from where you're looking
yeah
and for the first time if you're looking
in that direction which is backwards
there you see the guru shining in the
heart and not outside as the body
because you then don't see yourself as
the body and you remain just as seen
he's brilliant he's brilliant really
brilliant yeah
brilliant
how how we're responsible for our own
happiness
and we are that happiness which we look
for
take it this way
when we desire let's say you're you're
at home and you desire like um
chocolate okay
you go to this you you you take your
clothes you you take a shower you put
your clothes on
you go to the store you get chocolate
you go back home to eat it
to feel satisfied not because you got
the chocolate
but because your thoughts have subsided
and you don't have the tendency to think
about chocolate which you think will
make you happy
all we think
that all we think
um all the objects that we perceive as
in this will make us make us happy it's
false
it's just the ego
thinking
that will bring the success
but when we get the chocolate we eat it
and we feel like [ __ ] after
we felt good eating it because we didn't
have to think about getting it but after
we eat it it was just a form of trying
to obtain happiness and nothing else
it's the same with everything else you
have sex
you you strive to get [ __ ]
in the end you go to the club you get it
you get back home maybe even the sex
wouldn't be that good who knows you know
but after you ejaculate you see that you
have run
all this time
and compromised a lot
just to get the object which doesn't
make you fulfilled you ejaculate and
what
[Laughter]
what we desire
when we get it
we feel happy
not from the outside but from our inside
just because
thoughts settled and we can just enjoy
ourselves that's it
so why chase objects if the happiness is
from within
and in the chocolate and in the [ __ ]
and in the money it's very little
happiness there because it's projected
through the ego
that's like the main script of the
matrix
yeah
that's the simulation
[Laughter]
well how can you how can you escape the
simulation
other than
than cutting down the projector
of the simulation
whatever you do within the stimulation
is just the simulation
so really when we're tired about
searching for worldly desires
then
we begin searching for spiritual desires
it's even more dangerous because at
least with worldly desires you can get
them by hand
spiritual desires this is not by hand
you gotta search a lot
but even then when you're
when you're fully mature to stop seeking
all these spiritual desires even
knowing yourself
by the outside
you can really mature enough to see that
you are the simulation
and the only means to cut off the
simulation
is attending to that which created the
simulation which is the ego
but then the simulation vanishes and
there it is
it was always there yeah how could the
simulation be perceived without the
special ingredient which is awareness
no awareness no simulation
but when there is just awareness then
there is no simulation
that's why it's beautiful
yeah turning on the projection
so good
and all the stories
subside
yeah when it's turned off
no story can remain stories come from
thoughts
um
in um
in in hindu literature or sanskrit
literature they have these terms for the
destruction
the mind of the mind and
and temporary
stillness of mind
you can achieve temporary stillness
basically you can turn off the projector
from time to time by focusing on objects
but even then it's not fully complete
you know but then your mind is still
temporary and it's still and it's a
stillness of mind
in a way it's not destruction of mind
it's stillness of mind because it keeps
the objects
alive
and it keeps
the subject
somewhere else you know
so that's you can get a stillness of the
mind by mine you know you can
focus on the body you can focus on the
breath you can focus on
my nipples you can focus on anything to
steal the mind but
destruction of mind is when you're not
stealing it
by thought or by object
destruction is really when you turn the
projector off
and it just stays and no mind really
wants once once destruction
and that's why inquiry
is the correct
method let's put it this way right
there's a good example
instead of
the mainstream spirituality is like this
you're drinking you're going to the
doctor okay to the guru
and the guru says
drink this potion without thinking about
a monkey
and when you drink it you think
immediately about a monkey
but if you want to stop thinking about
the monkey
you'll fight you'll fight you'll need
the right guru to tell you
drink this and think of an elephant
when you think of the elephant you're
not thinking about the monkey anymore
this is self-inquiry you're not thinking
about the monkey mind you have no
business with it
you just attend to the elephant the
moment the monkey comes into existence
uh
this should be our only our only mistake
to correct
it's the only mistake
stopping to steal the mind by mind and
stealing completely the mind by
attending to our consciousness
then stillness of mind is a byproduct of
the still consciousness
so it's very simple
it's very simple
right
just like the mind
sees the room full of objects
the moment
we retract
and try to find the source of light
by which
the room shines and the objects are
seen then we go towards the light the
objects are nowhere to be found and we
remain as that light if we trace it back
to the source
is a way that you
describe it as
soil and then
and then
like that
and then
the inclusive so
oh
you you can't see so you can see so but
the moment the moment it's it's more of
this
[Music]
and then
all right
yeah
yeah that
kind of makes the
makes it bliss
oh yeah oh yeah you you can you can
truly feel blissful but it's not the
bliss we think about because even
um i'll talk from my own experience it
doesn't have to be this way for everyone
but bliss
is
the last
body
we have
to remain detached from
we gotta remain complete bliss is is the
last obstacle from my perspective
that keeps you away from clarity right
because bliss is very is like you know
intense it's a beautiful feeling it's a
beautiful sensation it's
you you you could stay like that forever
it feels good
but you still feel clarity is missing
clarity is not bliss
clarity is truth bliss is included
but it's not how we think
it's not that bliss as an excitement
or a
state
do you equate clarity with equanimity
equanimity as in as in what like like
what do you mean by that
like evenness
no
no it's a byproduct
equanimity would be a byproduct of this
of clarity
yes you need clarity you need
self-knowledge without self-knowledge
there can be clarity that's what clarity
is if you know yourself
that's all it that's needed i would say
you know automatically everything else
which is true but you're not bothering
about everything else since what you see
is just you
so you see equanimity and bliss as
byproducts of clarity
yes
because you can find a lot of folks um
sitting with their legs crossed and
bliss smiling and feeling good you can
find people
on dmt having these experiences
but none of them have clarity in clarity
the bliss comes in the form of silence
in the absence of thought in the absence
of noise
the bliss
is you
so you don't really know yourself as
bliss but you get to yourself by this
clarity
which you are
yeah it feels beautiful
i was looking forward to it and
it feels like something uh
something beautiful is uh sort of
blossoming here and
it feels nice to
to see what
what this will continue as
perhaps uh we may do further
conversations you down for that
yeah yeah
why not why not
cool
it's very simple
it's very simple
not having conversations with other
people
in my videos when i make uh
youtube lives
i mention this i'm talking to myself
in the sense that all there is is the
self that's the most beautiful
conversation because it's completely
silent
and you don't need it you're happy
with or without pizza you're happy with
or without [ __ ] with or without money
happiness doesn't depend on objects
happiness is our real nature
and everyone is entitled to be happy and
i would suggest to everyone that's
watching these videos
if you really strive towards happiness
make it seem so by your own efforts
just like you're striving to win a
basketball game with your team and your
your coach sees that you're putting in
the effort and and and can coach you
better
you know in the same way put the right
effort in
but
just like the coach will say don't be
stupid
and and play smart in the same way put
the right effort inside not outside
yeah
and then the coach is happy
because you're listening to the coach
the inner guru
laughs
what's the best shout out for
you is probably your youtube channel
it's probably the best place for people
to check out
check you out further is there right
yeah if they're interested they can they
can
have a look at the channel
yeah
and you offer one-on-ones also
yeah yeah for those who just for those
who are serious and
somehow disciplined enough to uh
this is not a message
it's just that they feel
uh this earnest desire to know
themselves that's it
right yeah yeah very important key
good because just like like you see you
know these boxers that
come from nothing and they became they
become world champions like mike tyson
for example
it's not about where you come from
it doesn't matter the the the past of
the seeker it doesn't matter all this
crap if you're willing to go all the way
within
that's all that's needed but that's only
for those who are tired of chasing [ __ ]
chasing money chasing outwards happiness
chasing even outward kundalini spiritual
[ __ ] experiences
only for those who are serious enough to
be honest transparent and see that dude
objects haven't helped you so far
so let's try a different way what you
have avoided the most
is this
gap
which calls you
from within this
seems like a mystery but it's you
and everyone wants to escape it because
within ego can stay
so all your
thoughts will vanish including your
individuality your personality it can
stay
there nothing remains other than god or
what is
thanks for coming on to you
thanks for your invitation it was great
i'm happy we did it there were some
people for
uh commenting on the channel for a while
saying they wanted uh this conversation
to happen so
and i've been watching you also emerge
for a bit and it's been fun watching
that and feels good feels like uh
something powerful here it's good
that's great it can be
something other than you anyways
so that's why it's beautiful
yeah
and thanks everyone for tuning in to the
episode
find all the links below
to tio's channel and
uh his one-on-ones if you'd like and
you can
like the video if it brought you value
you can comment below with your thoughts
about it if you'd like
and
subscribe to the channel subscribe to
theo's channel also if you'd like to and
share the video if you feel like it was
resonant and can maybe help others so
that's that's it folks thanks again um
i'm gonna pause the recordings and then
we'll uh
let's stay in the room for a minute
yeah
cheers cheers